Pranav I'm a teenager and they have
great plans but no resources what do i
do first off eliminate the mindset of
lack of resources you are walking around
in in a wasteland your mindset is a
waste line right now if you are walking
around with that attitude that I don't
have resources you have lost you have
already lost the people who have won
your idols your heroes where does it you
look up to started with less than what
you already have right now and if you're
walking around saying I don't have any
resources and I'm too young to start
anything then guess what you do you're
right you don't have resources and
you're too young and you're gonna lose
because of it but ultimately you've lost
because of your mindset the ultimate
resource is your resourcefulness look at
the people who are the kids of rich
people they have all the resources in
the world they have all the money in the
world have the best education the
connections to everywhere it's very rare
that the kids of rich people go off to
create amazing businesses it's not about
having resources it's about being
resourceful there's a great quote from
Steve Wozniak they said stop focusing on
what you don't have and instead start
thinking about what you can do with what
you do have stop focusing on what you
don't have and instead focus on what you
can do with what you do have if you can
get that especially at 17 if you can get
that you are set up to win for life
never ever ever ever ever ever complain
come to another chat talk to your
friends or your family or anybody else
ever including yourself never say I
don't have resources never you say that
you lose you got angry but but it's true
and I want you to win raise your
standard Apple at the core is core value
is that we believe that people with
passion can change not one drop of
myself work depends on your that's
something sue me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or absolutely incapacitated
hey believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten roses success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details